i think yeah
good great so hello and welcome to my
talk today i feel very much privileged
to kick start a wonderful scientific
journey uh for all the fellow science
iomix club members and other students
also so in this
short talk i will actually break down
the title
word by word to
finally reach a whole reach the holy
grail of how to build an interpretable
machine learning model for precision
oncology uh
when subrajid contacted me first to give
a talk he gave me i should cover three
portions i should cover how
bioinformatics has changed biological
sciences and i should cover some of my
research work and also some future
prospects in biology bioinformatics for
fellow students so i would
take this stage to mention that if it's
not for bioinformatics you and i would
not have been in front of this computer
talking about bioinformatics one doesn't
have to look
far ahead or far anywhere else to
notice the impact of bioinformatics and
biological sciences other than the
cancer genomics data so if you're not
familiar with that then go ahead to tcga
atlas and then you will know a lot more
about that and i would talk about my uh
my work in
java new university as i mentioned i
would break this down word by word to
finally wish you to a level where how we
we can build a machine learning model
for precision oncology with
interpretation
possible
and with that i would like to start uh
by asking you all to wonder
what is science
so apart from a lot of definitions one
can come up for science a short
description from another seminar i was
attending as a student resonates with me
and i want to share that with you all
science is a club
where everyone is passionately
discussing about something some agree
and some disagree with each other
no one knows who started the discussion
or when was it started you enter the
club you are overwhelmed and tongue-tied
at first you stand aside and listen to
the conversations after a while you get
a grasp of what is being discussed
you formulate an opinion for yourself
now you feel the need to contribute to
the discussion and you enter the table
you present your views at first no one
seem to take care
the more and more you talk about your
views people take notice many agree and
few disagree and over time finally when
you feel your time is up you leave the
club while the discussion goes on and on
and on so this yeah i like this
approach of how science has been
practiced
currently as such so let's
dive straight into the topic at hand
oncology oncology is the study of cancer
and cancer doesn't need any
introduction at all it is the leading
cause of deaths worldwide and the death
rate is predicted to increase despite
our efforts in treating cancer
and our efforts in treating cancer have
relied on drugs that are marginally more
toxic to cancer cells than normal cells
the problem arises in such situation
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond to cancer
drugs in comparison about 80 percent of
the patients respond to popular
painkillers that are available in the
market
one of the prominent solution to this
problem is precision oncological therapy
where a treatment strategy is designed
by targeting molecular characteristics
of the patient's tumor cells
hence the treatment is personalized to
the patients who are likely to respond
to specific cancer therapies so
gone are the days where one size fits
all but now we
accurately predict or accurately try to
find out which medicine or which therapy
works at what level to different
patients thereby personalizing the
medicine to the particular patients
so precision medicine effort efforts
typically involves first
molecularly characterizing tumors using
next-gen sequencing techniques and then
systematically studying the tumors
response to multitude of therapies in a
suitable model systems for example
depicted here are
two kinds of model systems one are cell
line
in
here cell lines uh to which multiple
drugs are administered and the cell
lines tumor growth is being studied and
the next is called patient-derived
xenographs which i will talk about more
so i by doing this one can identify a
list of therapeutic options that is
personalized for the patient
the main hurdles for this kind of
therapy are even in developed countries
like usa and europe most of the
countries
large-scale implementation of such
precision medicine therapeutical
approaches are not yet very well
established the time required for
developing a good quality model system
is about three years
and in such a time three years the
tumor's progression
could alter its response alter its own
morphological and phenotypical behaviors
and hence its response to the choice of
the therapy and also not not to say the
least privacy issues surface once we
start collecting such sensitive data
that could identify the patients
but
the model system based strategy to
molecularly characterize the tumors and
to study their responses under under
multitude of treatment options can be
leveraged using bioinformatics to study
the biology behind the tumor's response
to
to different treatments
so how do we do that so to understand an
event or a biological process scientists
often resort to constructing
scientific models a scientific model
could be a physical or mathematical or
conceptual representation or all the
three of the processes involved
these models helps us to identify and to
understand and understand the underlying
patterns by analyzing complex data the
primary purpose of such scientific model
is to make meaningful predictions
so with the advent of big data and the
complexity of the data increases and
also the underlying pattern becomes
concealed within multitude of different
patterns that are not
of our interest in that complexity
complex data so in such situations the
ability of the machine learning
algorithms to learn and to improve
without being explicitly programmed is
being employed and how do we build a
machine learning model for precision
oncology so so far we have covered how
what is precision oncology and why do we
need models to study uh
scientific questions and now we go
straight to the heart so how do we build
a machine learning model for precision
oncology
so
to any scientific model the primary
component is good data so remember a
couple of slides ago i spoke about model
systems uh used to characterize tumors
so we can make use of that data that has
been that is made publicly available
from one such study that has published
nature in medicine in terms of 2015.
so the tumor cells so what happened in
this
study and also what happens in this
model system is the tumor cells from the
cancer patients are extracted and
subjected to next-gen sequencing
techniques and the information about
gene expression gene mutation and copy
number variation were extracted
this data this genetic data molecularly
characterizes the tumor at multiple
levels in this case three levels as i
mentioned and then these tumor samples
are then grafted into immunosuppressed
mouse and these immunosuppressed mouse
and the tumor samples are administered
several cancer drugs then the tumors
growth response to their respective
drugs are documented
this growth response data and statistics
records whether the tumor is sensitive
or resistive to different treatments
both the molecular characterization data
and the treatment response data are made
available along with the publication
and
such a wealthy of data usually generates
a lot of research questions and my
interest was specifically to use this
data to design and implement machine
learning models to predict tumors
response to different treatments
so
out of the five cancers studied i
focused on breast cancer and colorectal
cancer
and
the gene expression data the copy number
variation data and the gene mutation
data for which
there are total number of
genes
scan thousands of thousands and
thousands of columns
are the features from which the machine
learning model defines a function to
predict tumors response to a drug
so the tumor's response here could be
sensitive or resistive to a particular
drug so technically for this particular
study i use random forest model as a
binary classifier to predict the
responses of the test set into sensitive
or resistive so what do we mean by that
so
the training set of breast cancer and
colorectal cancer involves multiple
features as i mentioned and these
features could be from gene mutation or
gene copy number variation or gene
genetic expression data gene expression
data and so these features and these
and the
pdxs or the samples studied here
are then classified into whether the
samples are resistive or or
sensitive to the treatment administered
so we
split this data into a training set and
then let the machine learning model
learn the underlying pattern within this
feature set and their response on their
relation to the response variable here
which is the
treatment response and then apply that
machine learning model to a test set
which was set aside and not uh not to
overfit the data and then the
predictions from the test set are
reported this is how usually a machine
learning model
is being built for the data set so
in this manner the treatment responses
of breast cancer and colorectal cancer
are predicted for 13 separate treatment
combinations for each one of them
so
so how do we
how do we then measure or how do we then
uh
calib uh or quantify the performance of
the machine learning model so the
machine learning models performance can
be quantified by identifying four
measures that is true positive false
positive through negative and false
negative
so often
precision and a recall are used as
accuracy measures precision can be
defined as how many of the total
predictions that we made were actually
correct and recall can be defined as how
many of the total correct items
were actually predicted correctly so
that is what is given in this very uh
graphical uh explain i mean uh
schematic representation i love this uh
schematic representation but
for this for this
study's purpose i use
i use a parameter called matthews
correlation coefficient in short mcc
to study or to measure the accuracy of
the prediction model or machine learning
model so
why do i use this
so this this uh
metric actually uses all four
performance metric if you seen uh this
uh
measure actually uses all four
performance metric if you see the
formula
it uses true positive true negative
false positive and false negatives all
of them in the numerator mathematically
that is very important
and all of them in the denominator are
also denominated also that gives
this particular
accuracy measure very nice mathematical
properties one of such properties is it
is analogous to any correlation
coefficient so they lie between minus
one to plus one so plus one would mean
the machine learning models predictor
performance is perfect and -1 would be
the machine learning model's predictive
performance is very poor and 0 would
naturally mean it is random there is no
correlation at all so it is random
so finally how accurate was the machine
learning model so the performance of the
model was compared with the traditional
methods of prediction of predicting
treatment response so traditionally
single genes were used as biomarker that
predict the onset of cancer for example
uh
yeah you would you would know the bracha
genes
mutations and other mutation data for
breast cancer and other cancers were
used to do uh market were used to
predict whether
the patient is susceptible or whether
the
person is susceptible to
acquiring breast cancer or not but
these are biomarkers for the onset of
the cancer but they need not be the
biomarkers or the signature genes for
predicting the treatment response of the
cancer that is the problem that we have
so for many cancers the same biomarker
was employed to predict the treatment
response naturally this is not logical
and hence this is not an accurate
predictor so that is reflected in the
performance in the first in the left
part of this trap where the mcc curve
for different uh multitude of treatment
goes haywire and none of them crosses
even 0.5 and
and even if it crosses 0.5 they are very
well known
single gene
pathway influencer for that particular
cancer and when i use instead of one
gene model when i use all the
genes to uh
to train the random forest model and to
test and i see a remarkable increase in
the accuracy of the prediction
so thus
we see that the treatment response could
be predicted more accurately when we use
data from multiple genes compared to
traditional single gene markers
so okay we have a machine learning model
that accurately classifies tumor
responses but we as scientists are not
satisfied we would like to know more
like
we would like to know which set of genes
were major contributors so there comes
a slight uh
a dilemma so uh as the court
sufficiently explains there is a natural
tradeoff between the interpretability of
the machine learning algorithm and its
accuracy and in applica in application
so more
in most literature on
random forest model would tell you that
the level of interpretation from genomic
data is nearly impossible since random
forest is typically treated as a black
box model you put in data and you get
out predictions and you forget about how
that's been predicted and what has been
used so how do we
implement the interpretability in this
case which is which is uh one of the key
words in my title of the talk so is
there a better way to achieve the same
performance with a limited number of
genes thereby increasing your chance of
understanding the underlying biological
mechanisms say for example i just
plotted top 30 future importances in
this case but actually it requires
thousands and thousands of genes to
match the predictions of the machine
learning algorithm that was trained
using all the genes so one cannot
naturally analyze thousands and
thousands of genes for its uh pathway
relationship with the uh cancer data so
so what do we do now so in general there
are
only one way that we can go ahead in
this case so we have to use feature
selection in this case so feature
selection by meaning we have to reduce
the number of features or the number of
genes in this case that the machine
learning model learns the information or
defines the function so there are
very there are multitude of advantages
of feature selection and mainly
they reduce the number of features one
so one
can excuse me so
by reducing the number of features one
can reduce overfitting and also improve
the generalization of the model and then
two
to gain a better understanding of the
features and their relationship to the
response variable
and how do we do that in this data this
is the most complex step
so i employed a combination of
clustering and univariate feature
selection techniques to improve the
interpretability of the machine learning
model first the
thousands and thousands in this case 27
000 and something genes are subjected to
hierarchical clustering so this removes
redundant information by clustering
similarly expressed genes together the
centroid of these similarly expressed
gene pockets are then extracted and then
they are applied to univariate feature
selection which goes by ranking these
centroids relevance to the response
variable that is to the samples
resistiveness or the sensitiveness so by
ranking them we can use top 40 or top 50
in this case
a number that is empirically
defined
in this
project
so the top 40 ranked genes for this
model were selected and then they were
systematically uh
analyzed for better performance like uh
iteratively you go from top to ranked to
top three rank to top top four ranked
and then that's to top 40 ranked genes
to
to
compare their performance to the
performance of the machine learning
model that was
that was that uses all the genomic
information data so
we do this this is a complex this is a
complex system of reducing feature
selection so we do this because
of two reasons one our uh input data as
such has a lot of features a lot of
genes like 47 000 genes so traditional
method of uh
greedy algorithm which uses
n into n yet n uh not n indian actually
n permutation or combination level of
feature selection will not work here it
is it will take forever and ever to
calculate that and even
even methods like
frequency feature selection and
recursive feature elimination will not
work here that also will take lot of
time so hence
such a method of combining hierarchical
clustering and universal and univariate
feature selection were employed in this
case so
in the end of all this we were left with
around 40 to 30 to 40 most relevant
genes instead of thousands so with all
these complexity
did i achieve the holy grail of
balancing interpretability versus the
machine learning model performance
so you be the judge so you already saw
the first two part of these graph
proportions of this graph before so when
i include or when i employ this
complex mode of feature selection
algorithm the accuracy improves for most
of the cases
and in addition to that not only that in
addition to that uh when i employed or
when i included information from the um
from other uh
molecular features like uh
not only not only restricting myself to
gene mutation but also include copy
number variation and gene expression
data the accuracy of the low scoring
treatments could also be further
strengthened
when multiple multi-omics profiles like
these are uh employed to determine a
consensus of prediction
so
so all this means i could use all the
data in my hand to accurately predict
and that accuracy is consistent also as
you can see the improvement in the
distribution of accuracy across the
treatments from uh from a data set that
uses only single gene to a data set that
uses all the
multi-omics data and in in addition to
that in combination with the complex
picture selection algorithm
so
with this now i have a handful of genes
with their genomic data and i can
predict tumors response to treatments
with a reasonable certainty and and this
is where this project stands as of now
so
this handful of genes can further be uh
used to identify their uh
contribution in uh in the tumors
response or tumors resistance
to different treatments so in this case
of 13 different treatments studied some
of the important conclusions that we
obtained was there is no one size fit
all method in in cancer and the tumor
and the treatment
response prediction so you have to
use a specific machine learning model
for our specific model that is trained
on specific data for specific
combination for example you can see from
from this here from this bgj treatment
which is a very famous treatment for
breast cancer
this a single gene marker was
sufficiently important right throughout
the case and it
it ran very well in these first two
cases it ran very well in all the
compared to all the
complexity of feature selection and and
increase in information content by
increasing the genomic data available
but for the other cases i can
push the prediction accuracy from
absolutely negative to random
to all of them are almost crossing 0.5
which in this case of limited data sets
is very very high very good so in
summary i would like to
tell you that i have shown how to apply
machine learning models to multi-omics
data to accurately predict humorous
response to any given treatment so in
this study i found out that multi-gene
predicts predictors or machine learning
models that employ multiple genomic
information of drug response are more
accurate compared to traditional single
gene markers
so i also demonstrated how to improve
the interpretability of the traditional
machine learning models to answer more
biologically relevant questions
so
what more could be done in this in this
case so algorithmically the level of
multi-omics integra integration in this
algorithm is very very basic
like you predict uh you predict the
treatments response for the machine
learning model that that is being
trained for uh trained on different
omics data and in this and in the end
you just build a consensus of the
predictions from these three different
models so that is that is
the most basic multimax interpretation
at best so one can explore various ways
to integrate the multimix data even
before subjecting it to the machine
learning model algorithm and then
and then explore the possibility of
building models on this integrated
multi-omics data without sacrificing
performance or interpretability
scientifically the limited set of high
ranking genes could further be subjected
to pathway analysis or a similar
analysis to understand the mechanisms of
drug resistance on those treatment tumor
pairs where the response is consistently
resistant right throughout the
different data sets that we have try to
model the machine learning or try to use
to model the machine learning
algorithm so that concludes my uh talk
on my share today thank you all for
listening patiently and i will be very
happy to answer uh questions in this
topic or in any other topic that
interests you thank you very much over
to you suprajew
thank you so much dr raghavendra that
was an amazing presentation and i was
thoroughly surprised and also mesmerized
to learn that how machine learning
algorithms can be implemented to
analyze and to get certain
signatures that we can actually
correlate with what's going on inside
the cell and draw conclusions uh and
ultimately also develop various
treatment strategies
so that's a really
amazing
domain which we are entering and where
i'm sure that many students want to
contribute as well so
we would like to go through the
questions that we have in the chat
section for you
so
we have one question from sharmin and
she asks that what are the possible
options to predict one biomarker for
potential therapeutic target for cancer
for example can we target only cd44v as
the breast cancer stem cell for
potential therapeutic target
i mean
there are two two possible place here uh
surname so therapeutic targets are are
there uh they are
they are already done there are there is
a at least i think two drugs that are
under trials uh that that uses the
therapeutic targets uh methods uh
instead of the traditional all cytotoxic
methods but uh here i am involved in
actually predicting whether the cancer
at what stage
will respond positively to your
therapeutic targets or not so
right now
in the current field people have
actually gone beyond uh
trying to understand cancer
on the basis of single gene biomarkers
so now people understand and and and um
i if you are interested you can follow
the research of professor nitin baliga
he sees amazing in this aspect so
he and others have actually demonstrated
that not one gene but a link of genes
actually
alter
significant pathways in the tumor cells
and then they are responsible for
converting these normal cells into
abnormal or
tumor
cells so in this case all these uh genes
that are responsible
for
for this conversion must be targeted at
least in expression wise that's what
been shown in expression wise or in in
any other
genomic uh
level so that this conversion can be
reversed or at best this conversion can
be changed into a stable disease with
which we can manage so that is the best
that we can get so far so people have
actually gone beyond uh trying to
identify a single
biomarker or one gene that is
responsible for the
onset of cancer so i hope that answers
your question so maybe
there is still as i mentioned there is
still uh some classic cancer uh like
breast cancers at uh
year positive i think that is um
yeah that that that gets onseted by one
or two mutations or in case three but uh
that is it multiple cancers are now have
actually uh people have actually uh
demonstrated that it's gone beyond that
one gene uh biomarker level
all right thank you so much
yeah you can see another one
we also have one more question in the
chat section from one of our
participants this is from shenzheny
so she asks can we use this multi-gene
detection principle for simultaneously
detecting the response of cancer cells
as well as associated non-tumor
cancer-associated cells like cafs etc
i mean this this principle one of the
main issues i see as a data scientist
today uh
not only in biological sciences also in
data science being applied to all the
other
fields as well is the models that we
built are tuned or actually
hypertuned to the input data set and the
test data set that has been
input dataset that's been supplemented
and the test i said that has been
validated once you go beyond the
boundary the scope of the model actually
reduces so one natural uh
progression or procession from the from
the study that i did is to collect all
the
breast cancer or colorectal cancer
patients data from tcga and then try to
apply our model on that but that lies a
problem
their response might not be similar to
response in spite of establishing that
such a model system actually correlates
very well with the tcga patients so this
this uh proposal that i am actually
making is currently under trial and con
currently under progress maybe i am also
interested to see what my peers in jnu
are trying to find out or will
eventually find out if one applies such
such a machine learning model to a to a
completely different data set and what
to find out so
the moment that you go beyond a cancer
cells that is
even increasing or more increasing the
potential scope of such
such a prediction so if you do not
supplement a machine learning model with
the necessary input information it will
not learn the underlying patterns so if
you supplement say these are the cancer
cells that we got these are the non
cancer cells that we got and these are
the responses for these cells for the
particular treatment now you tell me
whether this treatment is more cytotoxic
to the cancer cells or it is killing
more non-cancer cells so thereby i can
make effective treatment predictions so
this could be a good starting point for
a question like what engineers but
without supplementing the data of
non-cancer cells or cancer-solution
cells to the machine learning model you
cannot expect the model to predict uh
response of the of those cells i hope
that answers your questions if